being an artist wanting to make
something
how do we start with a blank canvas i
like to start with an
idea
ideas come from sensations you don't
have ideas
without having sensations
the art is never in the painting that
you're looking at or the surface of the
sculpture
the art is inside you when the lights at
the museum
go off nothing's happening there but
within you
everything exists
we're going to be speaking about the
ready made which is pulling
an object from its everyday situation
and bringing it into a context where
it could take on different meaning
i want to show you the major building
blocks of art
color colors carry meaning texture
i feel my fingers want to stretch out i
get goosebumps i want
more scale how big do you want to make
that
and form as we go into the
three-dimensional we're dealing with
form but there are no rules everything
in your life
is source material and the more you open
yourself the more meaning you'll find in
every action you take
there is nothing special about me
there's nothing special about my
experiences other than they were my
experiences and i've embraced them
your experiences your memories
everything about you
it's perfect
the only thing that is necessary is that
you have the confidence in yourself
to follow your interest and to share
those interests with other people
everybody that's interested in being an
artist
the world needs you i'm jeff koons and
this is my master class
[Music]
you